Y a esta hora hay muchas incógnitas
abiertas hay muchas preguntas por
resolver Y precisamente previamente Luis
Manuel analista de seguridad y defensa
nos hizo su lectura del acuerdo entre el
grupo Wagner y el kremlin
en este acuerdo que se haya podido
llegar a cabo con Bielorrusia es para
que el líder de Wagner o sea
salga de Rusia y establezca sus
operaciones militares dentro de lo que
es el territorio de Bielorrusia esto le
va a dar entonces al grupo Warner una
autoridad Autónoma completamente y se va
a convertir en un grupo Mercenario
muchísimo más peligroso de lo que es
ahora también en este acuerdo que se ha
llevado a cabo Pues estamos viendo de
que hay mucho dinero de por medio Fíjate
que en el Ministerio de defensa ruso lo
que hizo fue quitarles a todos esos
Soldados del grupo Warner y los obligó a
que firmaran un contrato con el
Ministerio de defensa ruso eso le quitó
muchísimo dinero
y en estos momentos es lo que ha estado
ha sido tratando de negociar el futuro
de lo que sería el grupo Warner y su y
Su futuro financiero eso es lo que
estamos viendo con este contrato con
esta negociaciones entre Bielorrusia el
grupo guarne y lo que sería el
presidente en Vladimir Putin por otro
lado Luis Manuel royé también nos
explicó qué interés puede tener esta
situación para Vladimir Putin
Bueno mira desde un punto de vista de
inteligencia yo te digo que esto es más
bien quizás un autogolpe por parte del
presidente Vladimir Putin Fíjate que la
narrativa que ambos han usado Vladimir
Putin y ha sido bastante respetuosa
prigosis le sigue diciendo habla de mí
Putin el presidente y
Vladimir Putin no se ha dirigido
directamente
O sea que han mantenido la distancia
esto es más bien Es para proteger a
Vladimir Putin que en estos momentos
crea el escenario perfecto para que
Putin implemente medidas drásticas en
Rusia para reclutaje de nuevos soldados
para pelear en el conflicto de Ucrania
sin ofender a la élite oligarca que se
que existe en Rusia y que pudiera
revelarse contra Vladimir Putin por
tanto en estos momentos yo le daría el
mejor premio es un premio Oscar
actor geopolítico a Vladimir Putin
porque esto ha sido una acción de
del departamento Central de Inteligencia
de Rusia con la aprobación de Vladimir
Putin Y por último abordamos que
implicaciones puede tener también este
escenario pero para el ministro de
defensa ruso cerca
ha sido blanco perfecto para pregocen
desde hace muchísimos meses lo ha
criticado muy duramente ha criticado a
la élite militar de Rusia en varios
videos especialmente en la plataforma
Telegram y en otras plataformas vamos a
ver que Vladimir Putin como parte de
estos acuerdos de estas negociaciones
que se están llevando a cabo con el
presidente de Bielorrusia va a
reemplazar a varias figuras en este caso
asergation o como ministro de defensa y
también puede ser que reemplace a a
otras figuras a importantes dentro de
esa cúpula militar que ha fracasado en
esa invasión a Ucrania y por tanto Son
ellos los que van a pagar el precio son
ellos lo que van a a cargar con esas
culpas de esta
invasión a Ucrania que ha fracasado
completamente